hey everybody welcome back to reality
check now this week in honor of the
return of Seminole stealth series thief
a game where you play as this chap
garrets his primary occupation is you
guessed it a thief we're gonna examine
the sights of one of the major tropes of
all stealth action video games
so you successfully cased the joint to
plan your routes of ingress and all that
lies between you and this sweet sweet
bouncy is a posse of guards now hold on
a second you shouldn't just kill them
all you're a thief after all you you
have morals
you're not the mass murderer well no
sweat
simply equip your trusty blackjack sneak
in close and give them a swift crack to
the cranium down they go out for the
count for hours convenience itself but
is this possible in real life it's
certainly true that people get knocked
out all the time
maybe boxing in a car accident playing
rugby or when a handsome man enters the
room guys you made to fall down from
these stints of unconsciousness or being
knocked out typically only lasts for a
few minutes however in theif when you
blackjack some guy on the bunts they
happily go to sleep for hours and it's
not just in thief's name pretty much any
stealth action game where you have
non-lethal options and the same troop
occurs dishonored Splinter Cell Metal
Gear Solid the list goes on so kind of
whack to the head of a real person
really put them down for hours only for
them to subsequently return to the land
of the waking with no more damage than a
nasty bruise oh and probably a pink slip
for being a rubbish guard well in a word
no you see any blow to the head that
actually knocks someone out is
technically causing a traumatic brain
injury and the duration of that
resulting unconsciousness relates
directly to the severity of that injury
so while a loss of consciousness for 30
seconds to a minute will most likely not
result in any permanent debilitating
damage attractive an organ that puts
someone down for hours on the other hand
now you're talking some serious brain
damage
so why is this well first things first
let's look and see what happens to the
poor brain at the point where blackjack
meets skull
on impact the per brain move n gets
bruised at the point of contact the
force then propels it to the other side
of the scale where it collides bruising
it again and then it sloshes about for a
bit
best case scenario this stuns the
neurons the main functional cells in the
brain stopping them from firing off
there we electrical impulses this leads
to the loss of consciousness but
hopefully just for a few minutes
interestingly mild concussions of this
type can also cause anterior grade
amnesia meaning you forget things that
happen before the why to the head so if
that guard was to wake up in a few
minutes not only would he not remember
why he's sprawled out on the floor but
he might also not be able to recall what
he had for breakfast that morning
now in the case of a blow that can KO a
person for hours the type that Garrett
regularly dishes out then we were
probably talking about a cerebral
haematoma this is when the brain
smashing against the inside of the skull
leads to rupture of the blood vessels
which causes bleeding directly in the
brain as a cerebral haematoma grows it
damages or kills the surrounding brain
tissue by compressing it and restricting
its blood supply leading to symptoms of
stroke this is what causes the severe
brain damage now every time you ko
someone is garrote they stay down
so technically every single one of those
guards you think you've just put to
sleep in reality they would all be
suffering from cerebral hematomas I
would be in dire need of immediate
medical attention to relieve the brain
swelling and mitigate some of that
damage furthermore by hiding them down
in that darkened alleyway rather than
calling a doctor what you're really
doing is condemning them to a life with
severe brain damage that's if they don't
slip into a coma and ultimately die
thief hardly more like willful
brain-damaged man now obviously this
knockout 4-hours mechanic is present in
games like thief for good gameplay
reasons but is there a real-life
scientifically accurate way to put a
guard to sleep without the risk of any
nasty collateral brain damage or death
well it's a tricky one you see there is
no consistently reliable way to
non-lethal II sedate a potentially
hostile human now granted we sedate
humans every day in hospitals but this
is carefully controlled with a precise
amount of general anaesthetic prescribed
to the individual based on weight and
other factors
however shoots someone with a
tranquilizer dart another popular game
non-lethal takedown and you run the risk
of either not administering enough
giving the target time to raise the
alarm before they succumb or giving them
too much and inadvertently stopping
their hearts and killing the person yep
more accidental deaths in fact all
techniques traditionally thought of as
non-lethal tasers chloroform etc are
technically classified as less lethal
because there is always that
so will this knowledge bomb change your
skull bashing ways next time you jump
into thief or dishonor than the like let
me know in the comments down below or by
tweeting at me at scam phrase Rob last
week I looked into the sites of
titanfall and whether or not we should
expect real-life Titans anytime soon now
many of you noted that the tower system
I featured actually looked more like the
crisis Nanosuit than a giant Titan mech
you know what I kind of agree however
the key thing about the crisis Nanosuit
is its basis in nanotechnology for more
why not check out the crisis Nanosuit
episode of the what if machines where I
go into depth about the cutting edge of
soldier nanotechnologies also I get help
from the lovely and super-smart Sujata
Kundu thanks ooze and thanks to you guys
for watching another reality check I'll
be back again next Sunday of course so
see you then
you
[Music]